President Biden's visit was news to EU
foreign ministers who were at the same
time sitting down for a meeting in
Brussels to discuss Ukraine as the first
anniversary of the war approaches the
Dutch foreign minister told me it sends
a powerful message to President Putin in
a signal that the American president
gives is that we will continue we will
continue to help out Ukraine with
weapons we will continue to work out
accountability we will continue with
humanitarian aid for as long as it takes
and I think that is it is fantastic that
he is there other foreign ministers
reacted to the recent comments by the
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
that he feared China might be about to
start sending weapons to Russia the
message is don't do it because
everything like delivering further
weapons for destruction of Civilian
targets civilian infrastructure killing
civilian people kids children is
escalating additional war in Ukraine
there were those who expected West
Global North not to be United when it
came to Russia's attack on Ukraine or we
were United so there's a lesson in that
so I would I would think that drawing
from this lesson the the there will be
enough Arguments for China not to assist
Russia in its what I call genocidal war
in Ukraine the EU foreign policy Chief
Joseph Burrell told me if China supplies
Russia with weapons it will cross a red
line but he said at a weekend meeting in
Munich his Chinese counterpart had
assured him it wouldn't happen he told
me that they are not going to do it
but they don't plan to do it
but
will remain vigilant
EU ministers are also well aware that
China says it has a peace plan for
Ukraine that it's going to unveil in the
coming days diplomats tell me they'll
remain pretty skeptical until they see
the details James Bay's Al Jazeera
Brussels